so you're making the documentary you're
building a home which you've never
you're not a builder by trade how are
you structuring your day I'm sure there
are probably times when it's incredibly
overwhelming and you're thinking why did
I get myself into this but how do you
keep yourself on track because you both
seem very organized must be enabled in
order to pull this off maybe it looks
better on me but it looks beautiful from
the outside so how are you structuring
your day what you know the interesting
thing is that right I both also work
pretty um I work almost full-time and
Rhett works a lot to you yeah she also
manages a travel I explain it's kind of
like a slow food travel business that I
I do for my day job yeah um which is not
a very straightforward you know you
punch and punch out things so she's
always answering emails for our project
for that business and front of things
and and I work from home as a graphic
designer and programmer or two so it's
it can be kind of hard to keep those
various things and together because in
you know the building the house like you
said it and doing the film are two very
separate things and different kind of
parts of the brain and they both in
either one of them would have been one
of the probably the hardest project ever
took on but together if it was really
intense there for a while now we're
luckily we're just focusing on the film
and that's been great but we've also
been focusing a lot more on it so it's a
lot more intense in the post-production
process so so I don't feel like we've
slowed down an old but yeah it's been
going good yeah i mean i don't think
there's really haven't necessarily been
any method to sort of how we've done it
i mean it feels like i know you know
Christopher used to always say with this
with the tiny house but figuring out how
to build a house it was really just a
series of breaking it down into small
projects and like when you were doing
you know the framing you had didn't even
think about the electrical or I mean it
was really just like one step at a time
you know figuring out how to
you the project that was right in front
of him and and I feel like a little bit
less so for the film because we've had
to do a little bit more long-term
planning but in a lot of ways it's kind
of just been like focusing on you know
okay now we need to edit the rough cut
you know now we need to talk to our
friend who's doing the composing or I
mean it it feels like it's been sort of
just like treating it as a lot of little
projects rather than huge projects which
which would be so overwhelming yeah I
think that's actually pretty much true
yeah I think a lot of people don't even
start there's probably people out there
who want to make a film or maybe want to
build a tiny house but they don't start
because they see the project as a whole
liking how I can never make that house
or or do this like two hour-long film
once they start figure out what's
involved you know but then if you say oh
well you know I maybe I can't you tell
but maybe I could I don't know right
right out of the a treatment of a film
or something like that and you take it
step by step and then and if you don't
think about it in the larger project I
think you're a lot more likely to I mean
you have to keep an eye on it as a
larger project but if you focus on those
steps the larger project becomes a lot
more manageable
you